Michael Irvin three-time Super Bowl
champ course hall-of-famer NFL Network
analyst you can see NFL Network coming
up every Sunday morning they start game
day morning at 9:00 Eastern also
Thursday Night Football this week
bears-packers on CBS NFL Network and
Amazon Prime video let's bring in the
play maker Michael Irvin Irv how are you
this morning
good let me ask you this without naming
names of what recruiting was like in
just stories that you heard we're
talking about college basketball now and
there that looks like there's gonna be
some ramifications a bombshell dropped
on college basketball with you know
Paola here but well what was college
football like when you were coming out
of high school what did you hear what
did you see being recruited it is now
from a standpoint of you know so many
there's there's so many recruiting
wavers with so many recruiting wires and
programs and everything that everybody
is trying to get ranked in and all of
that stuff you know back then it was
almost like you play well and they'll
find you now it's you know you can find
the schools and you want to find all of
these programs and so that means there
are a lot of other people in the middle
of giving you to where you want to be
and you know TV it's just like what you
guys are talking about now when you
start getting a lot of other people in
the middle and they start getting things
then a lot of other stuff comes in yeah
you got the middlemen these AAU coaches
or assistant coaches and then they get
in with wanna get the kid and that
person is trying to use the kid to get
to where he wants to get you know
universities or financially and
everything so they change so much it's
really scary now all right let me start
with Cowboys prior to the game with the
show of unity involving Jerry Jones what
did you think of what you saw last night
all weekend long
it was just an incredible show of unity
from from everyone after what we heard
from from from president Trump and it is
attack on what Isis is attacked to be on
especially African American players and
in the tone in which he took in his
statement and the names and which he
called football players exercising their
First Amendment rights and and I have on
my show on our show I said there's no
way I could not back it up against what
I saw in Charlottesville and you came
out with such fervor called in
african-american players that Sobeys it
should be fired on the spot such passion
and the way he spoke about it and then
he did not speak with that passion and
fervor
when we saw what we saw in
Charlottesville against he didn't
denounce that like he was denouncing
players that were you know just
exercising our First Amendment rights
either so where you want man and we're
and now to come into sports and try to
divide everybody in divide the country
with the one thing that is always I mean
has always brung us together I said that
in my Hall of Fame speech back in o7
that this one thing sports is always
bring this country together and they
come in and try to divide divide the
country through our greatest passion I
just thought it was sad it was just a
sad day where do where do we go from
here what happens in week four in your
opinion prior to the start of games I
think you try to get back to normality
and everybody doing what are you doing
and get ready for a football game you
know it's just I don't think it's
something that you know extending what
we saw this weekend everybody will carry
out every weekend you know but but
you're still going to have reminisce
you're still going to have people that
are very passionate about it that still
do certain things and it's the swing
that's the reality of what our great
veterans and everybody
fought in the military that's what they
fought for they fought for you to have
that freedom of speech and have the
right to make the decision on how you
want to approach this situation he's
Michael Irvin the playmaker you can see
Mike and the entire crew NFL gameday
morning at 9:00 a.m. Eastern on Sunday
you have a pretty good idea of who's
good and who's not good so far three
weeks in the NFL shoulders down to come
together
[Music]
that surprised me
[Music]
hey people
protocol week one team one team where
Ezekiel Elliott is now compare him to
where Emmitt Smith was at this stage in
his career you remember there was
something special but so so sue is eek
you know and
Emma came in and him it was the ball cow
for our team in the nineties team that
you know went on to win three Super
Bowls week for this team everything
everything rides off of what Ezekiel
Elliott does on the football field and
how he runs the football but you I
thought you saw the Dallas Cowboys take
a a maturation step last night you know
prior to last night I thought they
needed Zeke to - are we going over $115
to win really win games in a sound way
last night they took a step you know you
watch that Prescott I tweeted out right
before he started doing that so we need
back now to use his legs you know and
then they came out with that one option
you know and that gets around the corner
and get a touchdown that's what you're
going to have to see the Dallas Cowboys
do more off so I'm a little worried not
as worried because that's pretty smart
about getting down you know him getting
hurt taking all of these runs but when
everybody's powering down in like that
it's tough for the line of scrimmage
that's the other thing that they have
that we did not have you know that
pressed I can get out and start running
and I think you have to split a little
bit more of that so everybody kind of
ease up and crowd the line of scrimmage
Jonesy Mike good to talk to you as
always and have fun this next week we
appreciate your time
[Music]
even though for me my you you don't you
don't give me the Heisman with a pie
like you you almost broke my nose there
I mean I did I took it easy on you
actually I said no poles cause he we
pulled out I said that poster everybody
where I would think I was literally like
you launched yourself in me into me with
that pie if that was college you would
have been ejected that was a targeting
targeting found you you're the bottom
here the vantes Burfict of pie throwing
is not a cheap shot artist is what you
are Mike I'm gonna get you again Mike
I'm gonna get you gonna get you you were
she knows Thank You Irv
it's Michael Irvin the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience